moi c'est mis un jour un nouvel élève
est arrivé je me paie le team et ses
garçons avaient un père mon père qui est
tombé amoureux de ta mère voilà comment
ma troisième vie a commencé
et moi ma seconde tu me suis accepterais
tu de passer toute ta vie à mes côtés en
devenant ma femme
même pas encore mariés et notre vie
sexuelle et déjà foutu et b ont dès
dimanche soir qu est ce qui prend ça
marchera jamais entre eux bonjour vous
comprendre le mariage vous n'auriez pas
une sorte de mode d'emploi émis 10
conseils pour un couple épanouie on va
tourner des vidéos
quel genre de vidéos au film les pensées
du bouquin premier conseil
aimez vous vous même je suis fan de toi
ça changerait quoi chez moi si tu
pouvais rien je vois petit road team 10
mois ce qui va pas rien pourquoi tu vas
pas faire du judo avec guilloton petit
copain juste roth
[Musique]
hop